if you've hired someone to remodel your
home and you realize you may have hired
the wrong person can you get out of a
contract well eric palacios has the
answer in today's legal minute sponsored
by eric palacios and associates
hi i'm eric palacios welcome to this
week's legal minute this is a question i
get asked all the time what contracts
can i cancel within three days
number one construction remodeling and
pool contracts the federal trade
commission mandates a three-day right of
rescission for all remodeling and
construction contracts and in nevada
pool contracts apply as well
number two any item over 25 dollars
purchased by a salesperson that came to
your house this is also called the right
of rescission or cooling off period
now here's the contract you cannot
cancel when you purchase a car many
people mistakenly believe that you have
three days to cancel a purchase of a car
that is not correct the only way you can
return a car is if the dealer has a
written policy to accept refunds or
exchanges don't forget to download the
eric palacio's legal app and we'll see
you next time on the legal minute
and for more information you can give
eric palacios and associates a call by
calling that phone number 702-444-7777